♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT COME
ANOTHER DAY, ANOTHER MASSIVE
BORDER FAILURE FROM JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO BORDER
OFFICIAL SOURCES, SPEAKING TO
FOXNews.com, BORDER PATROL IS NO
EXPEL MIGRANTS, DESPITE IT IS
STILL BEING IN EFFECT, BUT ARE
STILL PROCESSING SOME UNDER
TITLE EIGHT.
NOW, THIS COMES AS DEMOCRATS ARE
IN YET ANOTHER ELECTION DAY
CONVERSION.
YOU LOOK AT SWING STATES, BORDER
STATES, YOU KNOW, STATES LIKE
OH, BETO O'ROURKE RUNNING IN
TEXAS, ALL OF A SUDDEN, PEOPLE
LIKE BETO O'ROURKE AND, LET'S
SEE, MARK KELLY IN ARIZONA, THE
DEMOCRAT FROM NEVADA, ALL OF A
SUDDEN CALLING ON BIDEN TO DELAY
THE REMOVAL OF TITLE 42 AS THE
BORDER PRICES IS WORSENING BY
THE DAY BECAUSE AMERICANS ARE KN
BORDERS, THE RECORD OF MARCH IN
TERMS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY AND OF
COURSE UNDER THE SANCTUARY
STATES OF AMERICA UNDER JOEY
BIDEN.
FOUR IN TEN AMERICANS ARE STILL
HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, THINGS ARE ONLY
GOING TO GET WORSE.
MIGRANT CARAVANS ONCE AGAIN
BEGINNING TO LINE UP, AND OF
ACCORDING TO NEW FINDINGS FROM
GALLUP, SARA CARTER ON THE
GROUND IN TEXAS, BIDEN'S BORDER
CRISIS GETTING WORSE BY THE DAY.
ALL OF THIS IS UNFOLDING BEFORE
OUR EYES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW MUCH WORSE IS IT NOW THAN
IT WAS BEFORE UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW?
YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE FOR YEARS, AND
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WHEN
IT STARTED JANUARY -- IT
STARTED -- YOU CAN NEARLY PUT IT
ON THE BOOK, JANUARY, LAST YEAR.
IT WAS LIKE A FLOOD GATE.
THREE YEARS PRIOR TO THAT, I
PROBABLY FIXED, MAYBE FIVE, SIX,
TEN AT THE MOST HOLES IN THREE
YEARS.
RIGHT NOW, FROM THE DAY THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TOOK OVER,
I HAVE FIXED 172 HOLES IN MY
FENCE.
>> IS THAT A WARNING, TOO, THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE
REFUSING TO DO ANYTHING HERE --
>> THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO
GET OFF THEIR BUTTS AND GET DOWN
HERE AND TAKE A LOOK.
THE ONES THAT WANT TO VOTE FOR
THIS BETTER LIFE, COME DOWN HERE
AND SPEND A MONTH WITH US.
I CHALLENGE THEM.
COME DOWN HERE AND SEE WHAT WE
ARE GOING THROUGH.
>> IF THEY DO REPEAL TITLE 42,
IF THEY TAKE IT AWAY --
>> IT'S GOING TO GET BAD.
IT'S GOING TO GET REAL BAD.
>> Sean: IT WILL GET BAD AND
WAY WORSE THAN PEOPLE THINK.
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SARA CARTER JOINS US NOW.
SHE IS IN McALLEN, TEXAS,
TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, SO, WE KNOW IT IS
GETTING WORSE BUT IT IS KIND OF
INTERESTING TO WATCH THE
POLITICS OF THIS.
THEY MIGHT DELAY THE REPEAL OF
TITLE 42, WHAT, TO HELP
BETO O'ROURKE OUT?
HELP NEVADA SENATOR OUT?
MARK KELLY OUT IN ARIZONA, IS
THAT THE ONLY REASON FOR THE
DELAY?
AND THEN AS SOON AS THE ELECTION
IS OVER, THEY WILL GO AND REPEAL
AFTER THE ELECTION?
THAT IS THE WAY I SEE IT.
>> WELL, SEAN, THAT IS WHAT THEY
ARE FEELING FROM THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
YOU HAVE SENATOR MARK KELLY,
KYRSTEN SINEMA, OTHERS,
SENATOR CHRIS COONS, A DEMOCRAT
HERE IN TEXAS, HENRY CUELLAR,
THE CONGRESSMAN, WHO FOR A LONG
TIME, GIVE HIM BACK, HAS BEEN
FIGHTING BOTH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND NOW OBVIOUSLY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO STOP
THE FLOOD GATES FROM.
RIGHT NOW UNDER TITLE 42 THEY
WERE ABLE TO EXPEL -- THAT IS
ACCORDING TO BORDER PATROL
NUMBERS -- ABOUT 110,000 PEOPLE
BACK TO MEXICO.
THEY RETURN THEM BACK TO MEXICO.
THEY ARE EXPECTING, ONCE TITLE
42 DROPS, MAY 23RD, RESCINDED BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE ARE
LOOKING AT 18,000 PEOPLE A DAY,
THAT IS ACCORDING TO NUMBERS NOW
COMING FROM DHS.
I AM RIGHT HERE ON THE BORDER,
SEAN, RIGHT ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER FROM YOU, YOU
CAN SEE BEHIND ME, VERY DARK
RIGHT NOW, IS MEXICO.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT BEFORE I
GOT ON WITH YOU, I WAS WATCHING
PEOPLE IN THE BRUSH HIDING IN
THE BRUSH LOOKING AROUND, BORDER
PATROL HELICOPTERS UP ABOVE,
BORDER PATROL PATROLLING THE
RIVER, AS WELL AS NATIONAL
GUARDS RIGHT BEHIND ME.
IMAGINE THE WAY IT IS NOW, 79%
INCREASE SINCE LAST FISCAL YEAR.
THIS YEAR ALONE IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS, SINCE OCTOBER, THERE HAS
BEEN OVER 1 MILLION PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
IN MARCH ALONE, 80,000 PEOPLE
WERE RELEASED INTO THE NATION.
THAT IS A 79% INCREASE.
AND WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING AND EXACTLY
WHAT THE RANCHER WAS SAYING AND
EVERYONE ELSE IS SAYING IS LOOK,
THIS IS A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
IT IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE IF
THEY RESEND TITLE 42.
>> Sean: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE,
AND MARCH WAS THE WORST OF ALL,
WHAT, 220,000 ENCOUNTERS WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, THOSE ARE
THE ONES WE KNOW ABOUT.
>> CORRECT.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE RECORD.
>> THOSE ARE JUST IN MARCH.
220,000 ENCOUNTERS IN MARCH,
80,000 RELEASED INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THOSE OF THE NUMBERS THAT THEY
ARE GIVING US RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: AND BY THE WAY, THE
ONES THAT AREN'T RELEASED INTO
THE COUNTRY, THEY JUST GO
THROUGH A DIFFEREN